There's been a little bit of distance now since the passing of Steve Jobs and...
...you address some of the rivalry in the past.
But I'm really intrigued by the anecdote at the end of Walter Isaacson's book...
...you spoke about how in his final months you came to his house, came in through the kitchen,...
...and the two of you spent a couple of hours together reminiscing...
...and really made peace despite years of your ideological differences.
What do you remember about that time?
Well, Steve and I about four years ago had a joint interview at the D Conference...
...where we talked about how exciting it had been.
And in our career, the Macintosh work, the early work...
...I'd bet Microsoft's future on and Steve had kind of bet his career on it.
And that was our most intense working together.
Before that, I'd done the BASIC for the Apple II,...
...but that was more with Wozniak than with Steve.
And so Steve had a very different set of skills than I did.
He was every bit as intense, believed in revolutionary ways of using computers,...
...but in a not kind of an engineer approach, more of a design approach.
And that had huge strengths, particularly the last episode where he ran Apple,...
...he was able to do incredible work.
So he and I always enjoyed talking.
He would throw some things out, some stimulating things.
We talked about the other companies that had come along.
We talked about our families and how lucky we've both been in terms of the women we married.
It was great, relaxed conversation.